hey guys i'm hari i'm the guy behind
logically answered and i'm indeed not a
robot
with that out of the way let's jump
straight into the questions first up we
have how old am i i am 19 years old and
i was born on february 1st 2002
this question was actually asked by my
brother and he has his own youtube
channel as well he is almost at 1 000
subscribers and i think it would really
make his day if you guys could go ahead
and check it out that would be awesome
anyway the next question is am i indian
and the answer is yes i am indian and i
speak tamil but i was born in new york
and i've lived in america for the
entirety of my life
when i was three years old we moved to
austin texas and we've been here ever
since and i love it here can i do a face
reveal well here you have it but my face
isn't actually a secret my first few
hundred videos actually show my face all
the time
next up we have am i married and do i
have a significant other well i'm only
19 years old so i'm not married and i
don't have a significant other either
moving on to occupational questions we
have where do i work am i a student well
i'm a student at the university of texas
at austin and i'm majoring in aerospace
engineering i'm currently a junior and
the plan is to graduate in december of
2022. now i know a lot of you guys will
be wondering why i chose aerospace
engineering and if i want to pursue a
career in aerospace engineering well
honestly i have no intention of actually
getting a job as an aerospace engineer
the reason i chose to be an aerospace
engineer major was because i wanted to
be a pilot and that seemed to be the
most correlated if youtube and
entrepreneurship doesn't work out the
backup plan is still to become a pilot i
would say i'm decent at physics and
engineering and i find it quite
interesting but in terms of a career i
don't really have any plans of becoming
an actual aerospace engineer
next up we have what is my background in
finance
well finance has been one of my biggest
passions and i've been involved in the
stock market trading and investing since
i was 14 15 years old
i think the stock market and real estate
are the two best investments in the
world and whether you're running a
business or working a nine to five i
think it's awesome to have exposure to
both stocks and real estate if i went
down the pilot route and i didn't have a
youtube channel i would say my biggest
side hustle would probably be building
up a rental portfolio in terms of
financial achievements and honors i
would say my biggest milestone so far
was winning icdc or the international
career development conference in the
category of personal finance in 2019
deca and icdc were by far one of the
best experiences in my life and if
you're in high school and considering
joining deca i would highly recommend it
next up can i play the piano well i
actually really like playing a piano but
i would say my specialty is playing a
violin
i started playing violin on my fifth
birthday and i've been playing ever
since so it's been about 14 years now
i'm not a pro by any means but if y'all
are interested in how i sound i'll leave
a link down below to me playing
mendelssohn moving into questions about
the channel itself we have why did i
call the channel logically answered
there's really no specific reason that i
named it logically answered i thought it
was a pretty broad name that described
everything that i'd like to talk about
originally the channel was actually
called hari's hobbies but i thought
logically answers sounded a lot better
next up we have what made you start
youtube well i don't actually have
anything against nine to fives if you
work in nine to five and make a solid
income and like your job that's perfect
but i always wanted to do something
bigger and reach a lot more people and
youtube seemed to be the easiest way to
do so since i was like 10 11 years old i
would always make videos for all of my
school projects in fact if you go back
to the first videos on this channel
they're all school projects so i really
liked making videos and youtube was one
of the easiest businesses to start so
for me it was a no brainer
but something i should note is that i
pushed off making a youtube channel for
so long i created this channel in august
of 2012 and i instantly started posting
videos unfortunately i deleted all those
videos years ago and i wish i didn't
because now we can go back and look at
them it wasn't anything really crazy
though it was just me playing a bunch of
games like geometry dash every time i
thought about taking youtube more
seriously though i always thought that
it was too late in 2012 and 13 i thought
that the og youtubers like marcus
brownlee nigahiga and dude perfect had
already conquered youtube and that there
was no more room to grow
in 2015 and 2016 i thought that the
mobile gaming craze was over and that
people like chief pat gaming with mold
and nick knight had dominated his space
but what i eventually realized is that
there was never a perfect time to start
it was always better to start two or
five or ten years earlier
there's a quote that's like the best
time to plan a tree was 20 years ago but
the second best time is right now
and the people that really made me
realize this was graham stefan and meek
evan and that brings us into the next
question which is which channels inspire
me well first off it would definitely
have to be graham stefan and meet kevin
in 2017 i was watching a lot of grams
real estate videos because i was
considering getting into real estate i
started watching graham steffenford's
real estate content but soon enough i
started concentrating more on the
youtube side of his business within just
a little over a year after starting
graham was able to grow to over 100 000
subscribers and i was like i guess it's
not too late to start right now
i didn't want to put off starting a
youtube channel anymore so i started
posting youtube videos consistently at
the end of 2017 and we've been at it
ever since
also meet kevin was posting his exposing
grant cardone videos and those got an
insane amount of views for how many
subscribers he had at the time that made
me realize that even small channels
could get a lot of views if they posted
the right content so i would say meet
kevin and graham stefan were the two
that really inspired me to take youtube
seriously in terms of what i want my
channel to be like though i would say
the biggest inspirations are channels
like cursed cassot infographics show
window reproductions half as interesting
kento bento jake tran and many many more
along those lines and that brings us
into the next question which is why i
make informational content instead of
gaming and vlogs
as i touched on before i actually
started off making gaming videos but the
reason i switched informational videos
is because i think they're more
sustainable and more valuable long term
along the same lines we have a question
from ming who asked why i switched from
technical informational content to
science and finance content the answer
is that when i started making
informational content i really wanted to
make science and finance content but at
the time i was only 15 16 years old so i
didn't think anybody cared about what i
had to say about these topics
technology however is more of a teen
topic and most gamers are high schoolers
or college students so when i started
taking youtube seriously i started
making videos about technology gaming
gpus cpus gaming pcs and so on and so
forth but eventually i came to the
realization that if i didn't switch
right then it would just be even harder
to switch later on so i decided to just
give it a shot that question was from
ming and he's been around since 1 000
subscribers so big shout out to ming
next up we have why do i make so many
videos about elon musk well within the
science and tech community i would say
that elon musk is by far the most
exciting person to cover he has insane
ideas extremely ambitious goals and it's
just really fun to cover his projects
and that brings us into am i an elon
musk fanboy well i am a big fan of elon
musk his companies and his work but i
wouldn't exactly say that i'm a fanboy i
think spacex and tesla will be massive
companies but at the same time i also
think that tesla is massively overvalued
right now and that spacex's timelines
are a bit too ambitious
i'm also not fully convinced about the
boring company or neural link quite yet
but i'm happy to be proven wrong
moving on we have by far the most
requested section which is how i make my
videos the first question is how do i
think of my video ideas a lot of people
have actually asked me this in the
comments and i didn't really have a
straight answer but i've been doing some
thinking and i think the answer is
content consumption if i'm not making my
own youtube videos and i'm not doing
college work i'm watching youtube videos
and in most cases a lot of my video
ideas come from watching other youtube
videos for example graham had that one
video that was like meet the 250 million
dollar man and i made a video that was
meet the 10 trillion shadow bank the
other biggest way that i get video ideas
is reusing ideas that work really well
for example last year i made a video
about how elon musk will squash jeff
bezos to 1 trillion dollars that video
did really well and got over 300 000
views so this year i made a similar
video about a different topic this year
it was how louis vuitton seo squashed
tecmo goes to 200 billion dollars i
think having a good idea of the topics
ideas and thumbnails that work is the
best way to think of new video ideas
next up we have how do i research and
what sources do i use
all of my sources are always linked in
the description of my videos i would say
the three biggest sources for my
information are articles the companies
themselves and interviews in terms of
articles we have publishers like the new
york times wall street journals
bloomberg business insider market watch
cnbc things like that
as for information from companies we
have their websites and the videos that
they produce
for example we have the official
websites of blue origin spacex and tesla
finally as for interviews i listened to
a lot of interviews from billionaires
like larry ellison steve jobs elon musk
bill gates jeff bezos i basically listen
to all of their interviews i get a lot
of in-depth information from these
interviews and sometimes even video
ideas themselves
next up we have where do i get my video
clips from about 50 is stock footage
from story blocks and the other 50 is
from companies and news publishers
each clip is only a couple of seconds
and should be covered by fair use so far
we haven't had any issues with copyright
and hopefully that's the case moving
forward as well
next up we have how do i produce three
videos every single week and for this i
decided to just walk you through our
entire production process saturday
sunday and monday are my research and
scriptwriting days
usually i start at 8am and each script
takes six to seven hours to complete
after that i'll record the voiceover
which takes about 40 minutes and finally
i'll cut out all the errors and send it
to my editor by the end of the day
usually i'm done by 4 to 5pm on saturday
sunday and monday
my editor shout out to flick media art
will have the saturday video done by
tuesday the sunday video done by
wednesday and the monday video done by
thursday
on tuesday wednesday and thursday i'll
spend about one to two hours going over
this edit replacing some clips and
adding music
finally i'll spend about one hour making
the thumbnail and uploading it onto
youtube
the video that i finished producing on
tuesday will go out on wednesday the
wednesday video will go out on friday
and a thursday video will go out on
monday
lastly on friday i'll spend about one
hour finalizing the video ideas that i'm
going to be producing next week and
that's basically the entire production
process moving on to the last section of
this q a we have some miscellaneous
questions the first question is was this
my first channel and do i have any tips
for starting a youtube channel this was
my first channel and in terms of tips i
would say the four biggest things would
be it's not too late to start be sure to
target a niche demographic be on top of
your titles thumbnails and topics and
most importantly always be consistent
next up we have what are my future plans
with youtube well eventually i want to
experiment with animating my videos let
me know down below how you guys feel
about that
i also want to translate my videos to
other languages so that more people can
watch them and both of these should be
coming within the next two years
hopefully
that question is from evan locke who is
actually one of my elementary school
friends in real life he was one of my
first 10 subscribers so huge shout out
to evan locke moving on we have do i own
a business outside of youtube or do i
intend to
well me and one of my high school
friends leo actually started a business
during high school and sophomore year we
created an amazon fba business and got
like 15 16 000 in sales but we didn't
really make much profit so i wouldn't
exactly say that it was successful but
it was a great experience and we are
thinking about going back to it
also i do have an idea with an app but
that'll have to wait for another three
or four years as for the second to last
question we have do i trade stocks i do
trade stocks here and there when there
are some big events for example last
year i bought some calls on tesla when
they did the stock split and i bought
some calls on tesla when they were added
to s p 500.
i also bought some gamestop calls in
january and i made some good profit but
i sold that way too early finally as for
the last question where would i invest
all my money if i had to choose just one
company the answer to this is extremely
easy the answer would have to be tesla
but i do gotta say i think tesla is
super overvalued right now
we all know they're saying you can't
time the market but given how low
interest rates are and how exponential
the s p 500 has been i just don't feel
comfortable buying a tesla right now so
ideally i would wait for a bear market
in s p 500 before buying tesla
nonetheless if i had to choose one right
now it would still be tesla if i could
choose a couple of options i would wait
for things to cool down and then put 50
into tesla 25 into bitcoin and 25 into
ethereum
but that's pretty much it
once again thank you guys so much for
100 000 subscribers hopefully one
million is just around the corner but
you guys know the deal if you like this
video then make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
we have a weird question here from
monish which asks what is the biggest
gift you have ever given
i don't want to drop any names so i'll
just say it was to someone called jpb